vamos a aplicar la fórmula que deducimos
en el vídeo anterior y que en ocasiones
se le conoce como la fórmula de einstein
muy bien y esto es por supuesto para la
suma de velocidades y veremos lo
estupenda que es esta fórmula así que
recordemos que yo me encontraba flotando
en el espacio verdad me encontraba a la
deriva y entonces denota vamos con ese
me marco de referencia pero teníamos una
amiga digamos nuestra que viajaba en
esta nave espacial que viajaba con
cierta velocidad ve así que para ir
digamos sentando ideas vamos a poner que
esta velocidad ve fuera igual a siete
décimas partes de la velocidad de la luz
es decir que fuera 0.7 por la velocidad
de la luz y digamos que este tercer
personaje que se encuentra en esta nave
espacial y que lleva una velocidad o
digamos en mi marco de referencia verdad
de hecho vamos a vamos a cambiarle la
dirección de la velocidad para qué
digamos sea mucho más interesante vamos
a suponer más bien que este personaje
más bien se mueve hacia mi verdad hacia
donde nos encontramos nosotros vamos a
cambiar la digamos la orientación de la
nave verdad y suponemos que este tercer
personaje viaja hacia mí siguiendo esta
dirección y vamos a suponer que la
velocidad relativa que lleva es de la
mitad de la velocidad de la luz pero en
dirección contraria verdades serían
menos 0.6 menos 0.5 por la velocidad de
la luz muy bien entonces hay que
recordar que tanto como ve están dados
en mi marco de referencia verdad así que
si estuviéramos por ejemplo en un mundo
newtoniano y yo me estoy moviendo a 70
kilómetros por hora verdad y este otro
viene a 50 kilómetros por hora pero en
dirección contraria es es decir se
dirige hacia mí entonces parecería que
digamos desde mi punto de vista
viajaría a 120 kilómetros por hora
esencialmente lo que estaríamos viendo
es que se suman las velocidades verdad
entonces siguiendo esa analogía para
este personaje que va en esta nave
espacial digamos en un mundo newtoniano
parecerá que el otro viajaría a 1.2
veces la velocidad de la luz y ya vimos
que eso viola las leyes del universo así
que para suerte nuestra tenemos esta
fórmula de einstein así que vamos a
aplicarla para hallar la velocidad de
este personaje en el marco de referencia
s prima muy bien entonces lo primero que
tenemos que hacer es cambiar el valor de
verdad en este caso
vale menos 0.5 c esto será menos 0.5 c
verdad aquí también para usher a menos
0.5
muy bien lo estoy haciendo chiquito para
que quepa aquí ok ahora el valor de d en
este caso estamos suponiendo que es 0.7
ce verdad aquí será también 0.7 ce muy
bien ahí tenemos ya la sustitución del
valor vive así que veamos cuánto vale
digamos esta parte de acá arriba bueno
tendremos menos 0.5 c menos 0.7 sea
verdad aquí tenemos un menos entonces lo
que tenemos acá arriba será menos 1.2 c
y si nos fijamos muy bien esta es la
velocidad que esperaríamos digamos si
viviéramos en un mundo newtoniano pero
para suerte nuestra tenemos este otro
digamos este denominador verdad este
factor que digamos no nos va a permitir
que superemos la velocidad de la luz muy
bien entonces esto vamos a calcular lo
tendremos que
dividir entre 1 - el producto de menos
0.50 por 0.7 c entonces aquí tendremos 1
menos
aquí tenemos menos por más es menos 0.50
por 0.7 c simplemente de 0.5 por 0.7 eso
es 0.35
por ser es cuadrada y dividimos entre
pse cuadrada verdad entonces aquí
tenemos menos y menos simplemente
podríamos eliminar este menos y ponerlo
como más
aquí tenemos más y podemos ver que ésta
se cuadrada se cancela con la que
tenemos en el denominador verdad
entonces esencialmente lo que tenemos es
lo siguiente menos 1.2 c
dividido entre 1 + 0.35 verdad entonces
esto es un 1.35 así que tendremos lo
siguiente será 1.2 dividido entre 1.35 y
eso nos da 0.8 8888 vamos a redondear lo
mejor como 0.89 muy bien entonces esto
será aproximadamente esto será
aproximadamente 0.89 ce verdad y lleva
un signo menos porque aquí tenemos este
signo menos muy bien entonces de de
hecho déjenme ponerlo acá arriba verdad
esta velocidad será menos 0.89 veces la
velocidad de la luz verdad así que todo
esto tiene sentido verdad porque desde
el punto de vista de mi amiga desde el
punto de vista de mi amiga
esta nave parece que va mucho más rápido
que lo que va en mí
de referencia verdad de hecho en el mío
parece que va a digamos a la mitad de la
velocidad de la luz en dirección digamos
aproximándose hacia mí verdad y en
cambio en su marco de referencia va a
0.89 veces la velocidad de la luz y en
dirección hacia ella verdad del signo
menos sólo nos da la dirección a la que
se está moviendo esta nave espacial pero
en realidad no hemos violado el
postulado fue fundamental de la teoría
de la relatividad en donde nada puede ir
más rápido que la velocidad de la luz y
esta velocidad de la luz es absoluta así
que al menos al menos a mí esto me
parece sumamente interesante de hecho he
pensado a menudo en algún día no sé tal
vez diseñar un videojuego en donde se
considere todo esto que en realidad
digamos que todas las cosas vuelen con
distintas velocidades relativas pero en
donde se apliquen la relatividad
especial